did you know that so many people asked
us what a great starter microscope was
that we created one that's right you can
get the journey to the microcosmos
microscope at
microcosmos.store and we've also got
filters and slides and other supplies
even it's very cool Hydra t-shirt all of
that and more at microcosmos.store
[Music]
yeah
one of the most spectacular details of
animals in our world is just how varied
their colors can be when you look at
birds for example you'll see everything
from mundane Grays to iridescent Blues
Birds sometimes craft those colors using
melanosomes an organelle that holds the
pigment melanin and nothing about that
is particularly unique to birds we have
melanosomes as well and we use melanin
to make our various skin colors so then
why don't we ever shine with the same
iridescence as Birds
well we could just blame it on light
it's always doing weird things playing
tricks with what we see so let's just
say that light is doing something funny
and then call it a day
except that's very unsatisfying isn't it
if light has somebody tricks up its
sleeves that only makes me want to know
more about the specific tricks it's
playing with bird feathers and that
means we're gonna have to start this
hunt by talking about color specifically
pigments
oh
pigments are the compounds that color
everything from our paints to our
cosmetics and we see them all the time
in the micro Cosmos perhaps most common
of all would of course be the color
green found in cyanobacteria and
euglenoids and plenty of other
photosynthetic organisms thanks to the
pigment molecule chlorophyll when white
light hits the chlorophyll the molecule
absorbs the red and blue wavelengths but
it also reflects the green wavelengths
back at us which is how pigments work
they are molecules that absorb certain
wavelengths and in turn they reflect a
particular wavelength of light back at
us which to our eyes then looks like
color so when we look at these
hematococcus and see a mix of green and
red what we're actually seeing is a
mixture of pigment molecules reflecting
different wavelengths of light there's
the chlorophyll reflecting green and the
astaxanthin pigment molecule reflecting
red light back at us and so the lesson
we take from pigments is that light
doesn't just shine it reflects and
absorbs
but and also does more than that much
more
that became very clear to Robert Hook
who in 1665 published was probably one
of the most important texts in
microscopy history
micrographia or some physiological
descriptions of minute bodies made by
magnifying glasses with observations and
inquiries thereupon
this work contained detailed
descriptions and illustrations of
objects hook examined under the
microscope including the feathers hook
found from peacocks ducks and other
birds hook compared the structures he
saw on the iridescent peacock feathers
to pearls which as he wrote quote do not
only reflect a very brisk light but
tinge that light in a most curious
Manner and by means of various positions
and respect of the light they reflect
back now one color and then another and
those most vividly
and scientists began to better
understand what light is and how it
interacts with the world around it they
were able to understand what was
happening the light was not getting
absorbed and reflected by a pigment it
was interacting with the physical
structures within the feather refracting
and diffracting and scattering and
whatever else light can do the result to
our eyes is structural color a color
whose wavelength is the result of the
structures the light was moving through
and for some structural colors the angle
of the viewer relative to what they're
looking at will change the color itself
and this produces iridescence
you can think of the difference between
pigments and structural color as kind of
like the difference between looking at a
crayon and a rainbow when we see a
rainbow we're not looking at colored
water we're seeing light refract and
reflect and disperse in those water
droplets except at the end of the day a
rainbow is a function of the rain and
the sunshine in your eyes making it an
illusory object that you can of course
never touch or find the end of
feathers on the other hand are very
tangible and the structures they use to
craft their colors are very present and
observable but before we dive too deep
into how feathers use structural color
we should note that birds can and do use
pigments as well for their coloring
mixing carotenoids melanins and
porphyrins for their various Hues but
birds can also expand on that range
using structural colors the blues you
see in these feathers here are
structural color blue pigment is
unusually difficult to find in nature so
when the color does appear like in these
feathers or in the wings of a butterfly
it is often from structural color now
the structures that make that happen are
located in the barbules those tiny
interlocking threads that make a feather
feel you know like feathery inside the
barbedules are keratin and melanosomes
those melanin-containing organelles we
mentioned in the the beginning of the
episode and it's the arrangement of
these melanosomes within the Keratin
that creates the structures that will in
turn determine the color of the feather
now a lot of animals including again us
have melanosomes but birds are unique
because their melanosomes can be Hollow
and the more Hollow the melanosome
scientists have found the more
iridescent the feathers and if they
produce thinner melanosomes that are
shaped more like a flat plate than a rod
the iridescence will only increase
these features of the melanosomes are
essentially changing the way that light
moves through the feather crafting a
different color
scientists are still learning about how
these structural colors have evolved in
feathers and why there is so much
variety and color and iridescence across
different bird species these are
structures that once contained pigments
but evolved to contain nothing because
being empty somehow made even more
brilliant colors it is a wild leap to
make but of course Evolution doesn't
think if color is produced and it
confers an advantage Evolution doesn't
care or know how this happened the
photons that would have existed whether
or not life ever evolved in our universe
doing a marvelous dance in the empty
pigment organelles of a bird's feather
it evolved without anyone ever knowing
how it worked until us
until now
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us the people on the
screen right now they are our patreon
patrons they are the people that allow
us to keep on diving deeper into our
universe and as you go deeper you get
closer and Tiny things get bigger and
then suddenly you can see things that no
one ever saw before if you want to
become one of those people and also get
some cool perks you can go to
patreon.com journey to micro we really
do appreciate it and we really couldn't
do it without you if you want to see
more from our master of microscopes
James Weiss you can check out jam and
germs on Instagram and if you want to
see more from us there's always a
subscribe button somewhere nearby
[Music]
foreign